foreign
there has been a lot of news about
Chachi PT lately like people using
Chachi PT to write essays chat GPT
hitting 100 million users Google
launching Bard to compete against chat
gbt and Microsoft integrating Chachi PT
into all their products and also the
viral sensation of cat GPT where it can
answer all of your queries but as a cat
meow meow meow meow meow meow
chat GPT if you don't know already it's
a chat bot by openai where you can ask
it many things for example explaining
complex topics like explain why I'm a
disappointment to my parents or ask it
more technical questions like how do I
inherit more money than my brother from
my parents
a lot of people are using it to write
essays draft emails and even write code
so
I tried it myself of course as a
YouTuber obviously my first question to
it was who is Joma Tech and it answered
you know chat GPT has a lot of
limitations like here we ask it to name
colors that don't have the letter e in
them and this is what they gave us
red that's clearly wrong in all
seriousness this is to demonstrate how
chat GPT works it's a pre-trained large
language model meaning it was trained on
text Data from the internet until the
end of 2021 so it won't know anything
about things that happened recently it
doesn't have access to the internet it
will only predict the answer based on
what it has consumed already and the way
it answers your question is by
predicting each word that comes next for
example if you ask GPT who Bard is it's
not going to know you might ask drama
Adventure Channel launch in 2017 and
Chachi BT it was trained on internet
data until 2021 yet it doesn't know who
you are
yeah so there's actually a technical
reason and you recently Chad GPT
hit 100 million users it launched
November 30th 2022 and this article came
out February 3rd 2023 so it took two
months to hit 100 million users who are
these users and what are they doing with
Chachi BT well it's pretty obvious
they're cheating with it everybody's
cheating such that some school districts
have banned access to chat GPT if they
can write essays then they can pass
exams chatgpt was able to pass exams
from law school business school and
medical school three prestigious
Industries now this is why I went into
coding because I always thought that law
school business school and and medical
school it was too much about
memorization and you're bound to get
replaced you know it just wasn't
intellectual enough you know
all right well I guess engineering is
getting replaced too chat GPT passes
Google coding interview which is known
to be hard but I guess not but note that
it is for a L3 engineer which means it's
an entry level for those not in Tech
there's no L2 and L1 it starts at L3 but
this does raise questions about tech
gpt's ability to change engineering jobs
behind it and we're already seeing the
change as Amazon employees are already
using chatgpt for coding even though
that immediately after they told them to
stop warning them not to share
confidential information with chechi PT
what's happening is they're feeding chat
gbt internal documents which are
confidential but open AI stores all that
data you know it reminds me of when I
used to intern at Microsoft and they
didn't let us use Google for searches
because they think that they might spy
on us I was like relax I'm an intern I'm
not working on anything important in
fact I actually wasn't working at all
you know I was playing OverWatch all day
but yeah anyways they forced us to use
Bing for searches one thing that's being
underreported in mainstream media is the
success of GitHub co-pilot it's probably
the most useful and most well executed
AI product currently out there have I
used it no I haven't coded in forever
now here's how it works the moment you
write your code it's like autocomplete
on steroids like this example it helps
you write the whole draw scatter plot
function and it knows how to use the D3
Library correctly
another example here you can write a
comment explaining what you want your
function to do and it'll write the code
for you sometimes even the name of the
function will give it enough information
to write the rest of the code for you
it's very powerful because it's able to
take your whole code base as context and
with that make more accurate predictions
that way for example if you're building
a trading bot and you write the function
get Tech stock prices it will suggest
hey I know you're going through a rough
time but building a trading bot is not
going to fix your insecurities and maybe
you should just accept that you'll be at
this appointment for the rest of your
life
okay
how did all this happen why is AI so
good suddenly the answer is the
Transformer model which caused a
paradigm shift on how we build large
language models llm by the way this
diagram means nothing to me it makes me
look smart so that's why I put it on
there before Transformers the best
natural language processing system used
RNN and then it used lstm but then
Google brain published a paper in 2017
called attention is all you need which
is also my life's motto because I'm a
narcissist
the paper proposes a simple neural
network model they call Transformer
which is based on the self-attention
mechanism which I don't fully understand
so I'll pretend like I don't have time
to explain it but I also know that it
allows for more parallelization which
means you can throw more Hardware more
gpus to make your training go faster and
that's when things got crazy they kept
adding more data and also added more
parameters and the model just got better
so what did we do we made bigger models
with more parameters and shoved it a
ton of data
sorry I'm trying my best here to
make the model bigger
all right it anyway that gave us
ready to use pre-trained Transformer
models like Google's Bert and open ai's
GPT generative pre-trained Transformers
they crawled the whole web to get text
Data like from Wikipedia and Reddit this
graph shows you how many parameters each
model has so as you can see we've been
increasing the number of parameters
exponentially
so openai kept improving their GPT model
like how Goku kept becoming stronger
each time he reached a new Super Saiyan
form while editing this I realized how
unhelpful the Dragon Ball analogy was so
I want to try again to recap Transformer
was the model architecture a type of
neural network other types of models
would be like RNN and lstm compared to
RNN Transformers don't need to process
words one by one so it's way more
efficient at training with lots of data
open AI used the Transformer model and
pre-trained it by feeding it a bunch of
data from the internet and they called
that pre-trained model gpt1 back then
NLP models would be trained from scratch
for a specific task like translation or
summarization both Transformer we get to
pre-train the model first then fine tune
it for a specific task then for gpt2
they did the same thing but more and
with a bigger model hence with 1.5
billion parameters and then with gpd3
they went crazy and gave it 175 billion
parameters however just like raising a
kid just shoving it with a bunch of
information
unsupervised might not be the best way
to raise a kid she might know a lot of
things but she hasn't learned proper
values from her parents so that's why we
have to fine tune it tell it what's
right and what's wrong how not to be
racist and clean up its act that's GPT
3.5 a more fine-tuned version of gpt3
with guardrails that can be released to
the public now you have a decently
well-behaved kid but you now want to
show her off so you dress it up nicely
get her ready for her first job AKA more
fine-tuning with some supervised
training so it behaves properly as a
chatbot that way it's well packaged and
is ready to ship to the world with a web
UI okay back to the original shitty
Dragon Ball explanation so you can think
of Goku's hair like the number of
parameters
175 billion parameters which is why you
can see Goku has more hair now Goku's
hair isn't much longer but it's just you
know styled a little bit differently 100
trillion parameters so technically gpt3
was already amazing but open AI was able
to package it neatly with Chachi PT
which made it user friendly so it became
a viral sensation so yeah packaging is
important it costs everyone to really
pay attention to this so how did people
react to the viral growth of chechi
beauty people were mind blown and said
Google is done because chat GPT is going
to replace search engines
no it can't until I can search for porn
it cannot replace search engines
oh wait
why search for porn
when you could generate it
[Music]
anyway even losing a bit of search
volume to Chachi PT would be a big deal
for Google since 80 percent of their
revenue comes from ads and most of it
comes from search people were telling
Google to release something similar
Google was like bruh we have Lambda
which is basically Chachi BT but
releasing it would be risky as they had
much more reputational risk at stake and
has to move more conservatively than a
startup would
that's foreshadowing by the way
Microsoft is chilling they position
themselves really well by investing one
billion dollar in open AI early on in
2019. that allowed openai to leverage
Microsoft's Azure for its compute power
to train and run their models and
Microsoft gets to integrate open ai's
Tech into their products so if openai
succeeds Microsoft succeeds and remember
GitHub co-pilot well GitHub is owned by
Microsoft so that's a huge win
meanwhile Google is panicking and issued
a code red calling in the OG Founders
Paige and Brynn
you know actually I have no idea who's
who so
um anyways but they called them to
strategize on how to approach this
Microsoft is feeling the momentum
especially with Chachi PT growing so
fast and the tech is very promising so
Microsoft invests another 10 billion
dollars into openai for a 49 stake in
the company that money can help open AI
I don't know unlock Super Saiyan 4 maybe
Microsoft also plans to integrate GPT
into Microsoft teams following the same
Playbook as what they did with GitHub
co-pilot which would be huge for them
Google also made some additional moves
Google invests almost 400 million in
open ai's rival anthropic which is
Pocket Change compared to the 10 billion
Microsoft invested if you don't know
what anthropic is it doesn't matter it's
like the Burger King of open AI
Google goes back on their word about not
launching a Chachi PD clone and
announces Bard AI HPT clone remember
when I said they didn't want to launch a
chat GPD competitor because of
reputational risk well funny enough
that's exactly what happened the AI made
a mistake in the ad and Google Shares
tanked losing a hundred billion dollars
and I still own my Google stocks from
when I worked there
the mistake was Bart said jwst took the
very first pictures of a planet outside
of our own solar system but this
astronaut said no it was not true
chovine did
that tweet alone
costed me a lot of money anyway
Microsoft responded to the announcement
by releasing a new Bing with chat GPT
built in to compete with Google search
meanwhile we have meta who is in denial
meta's AI Chief says Chachi PT Tech is
not particularly innovative
that is just massive copium finally we
got Netflix who's too busy cracking down
on password sharing to care about AI
all right what about us Engineers what's
the future for us the reality is that
GPT isn't replacing anybody's job
completely like most technological
innovations the change can seem drastic
because the media loves dramatic titles
but if you are open-minded you have time
to learn about it and embrace it rather
than fighting it if you're a software
engineer and you feel threatened by chat
GPT being able to solve fizzbuzz
oof then you should maybe consider
becoming a YouTuber
just kidding please don't compete with
me though you should incorporate chat
GPT and GitHub co-pilot to your workflow
it really removes tedious parts of
software engineering if you're working
in a new language or API Library you
don't have to Google sorry Google you
don't have to Google endlessly for the
stuff you already know just break down
and describe your problem to chat GPT to
get a huge Head Start or get good at
coding alongside Copilot if you
structure your code base well and write
good comments that describe what you
want to do co-pilot often gets the logic
problems right it's a symbiotic
relationship become the cyborg
see the trick here is that as a software
engineer your job is to translate and
break down a business problem into
software problems your job is to know
what questions to ask and what answers
to accept in fact here's my prediction
GitHub co-pilot is not done innovating
here their next big product release will
turn issue or PR description into an
actual full-blown code commit so as a
software engineer in 2024 you better get
real good at writing GitHub issues and
reviewing PRS
all right that's it for this chat GPT
video but I think this chat GPT
narrative is just one battle of a bigger
AI War that's happening between
Microsoft and Google I'll talk about
that next time see you and thanks for
watching and remember to call your
parents